>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> So I'm here to introduce a man
who has the unusual distinction
of having made a career of failure
and a very successful
career at that.
Professor Henry Petroski's
academic expertise is
in what's called failure
analysis, the process of collecting
and analyzing data to determine
what caused something to go wrong,
which is one of the things
that first drew me to his work.
Nine years ago this month
after two planes flew
into the World Trade Center
and a third into the Pentagon,
I telephoned professor Petroski
from the post offices and asked him
about what had just happened.
What about those structures
had worked
and what had failed,
I wanted to know.
And what could we learn from that.
The following week in the Sunday
Outlook section of the Post he wrote
from an engineer's perspective about
the impact at two different sites
in two different cities, one with
its buildings arranged vertically
in celebration of America's
towering supremacy,
the other horizontally crouched
symbolically in defense.
And he wrote about the effect
those disasters might have
on the future of building design.
With characteristic
for-site, he wrote,
the Pentagon will likely be restored
to it's full geometry long before
any decision is made about what
to do with the land on which
the World Trade Center stood.
The ability to breathe interest
into the objects that surround us
from great engineering feats
of our age like the Twin Towers
to the most mundane of
objects, memorably the pencil
and the toothpick, has
characterized Petroski's work.
He's a prolific writer, the
author of 15 popular books as well
as numerous articles and reviews,
some of which we've run in the Post.
Last year a particularly provocative
article ran under the headline,
want engineer real change,
don't ask a scientist.
Most people who aren't scientists or
engineers seem to think that science
and engineering are the
same thing, he wrote.
They're not.
Science seeks to understand
the world as it is.
Only engineering can change it.
And that's what his new book The
Essential Engineer is all about,
the role that engineering and not
science can play in responding
to the great global threats
we face from climate change
to producing clean
and renewable energy.
He even suggests that
science can sometimes get
in the way of technological change.
I'm going to invite him
to tell us how and why.
Henry Petroski has been widely
recognized for his academic
and literary accomplishments,
not only in his own field
of civil engineering, but
also through fellowships
in several gust bodies as
the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences and the American
Philosophical Society.
He's the Aleksander Vesic professor
of civil engineering and a professor
of history at Duke University and
the author most recently, as I said,
of The Essential Engineer.
And here is the essential
engineer professor Henry Petroski.
[ Clapping ]
>> Thank you, Francis.
That was a very nice introduction.
It's a pleasure and
an honor to be here.
And I've been enjoying the day even
though it is a little warm for me.
Francis made a very
good summary of my book.
And I'd like to elaborate on
some of the things that she said.
There is, I think, an incomplete
understanding of the difference
between science and engineering,
between scientists and engineers.
It's sometimes reflected
in the mass media
where engineers are just
grouped with scientists.
This is not absolutely speaking
incorrect, but it loses some
of the fine distinctions
between the two professions.
During the space race
back in the late '50s
and early '60s there was a
great need to develop a lot
of different rockets to achieve
what we wanted to achieve then
in our battle or competition
with the Soviet Union.
So it was news on a regular basis
to report on whether test firings
of rockets were successes
or failures.
When they were successes,
the headlines often read,
science achieves new record
of thrust or some such thing,
attributing the success to science
and by implication to scientists.
When there was a failure,
when a rocket failed to
ignite, it was a dud.
Or when a rocket did begin to
take off, but then went astray,
the headlines more often than
not read something to the effect
that latest rocket test,
great engineering failure.
And engineers, obviously
me included,
really tell that story
over and over again.
And they think it summarizes the
difference in the way scientists
and engineers are treated.
It has a lot of implications
not only for how they're treated
or how they're perceived
to be treated,
but also the status
that they're held in.
And this book that has just
been published is largely
about issues like that.
The fact of the matter
is, as Francis indicated,
there are distinctions between
scientists and engineers.
And the general way these
distinctions are framed is to say
that scientists study what is
originally the given universe.
Scientists are interested
in the planets, the stars,
the origins of the universe,
how old is the universe.
Questions like that are truly
scientific questions, but,
of course, scientists have also
been interested in what are the laws
of physics, what are
the laws of nature.
They look not only to the cosmos,
but also down into the atomic level.
And, generally speaking,
the principle objective
of science is knowledge,
understanding, facts, measurements.
Engineering, on the other hand,
as again Francis indicated,
seeks to change the world.
Engineers, the profession
of engineering would
like to develop better systems of
air conditioning tents in hot summer
or I guess we're in the Fall now.
And I guess they get
a lot of support
from that judging from
that response.
But historically there has been a
lot of engineering that was done,
believe it or not, without much
of a contribution from science.
It's a fallacy and it's a
very significant fallacy
that you take the results of science
and you just do something to them
and then you get engineering.
In realty it doesn't
work quite that easily.
This is sometimes called
the linear model,
that you make scientific discoveries
and then by some process,
which is seldom really
elaborated upon,
there comes an engineering outcome.
And, again, it's like the
attribution of the successes
to the science and the
failures to the engineers.
In the history of science, history
of technology there are a lot
of very, I think, convincing
examples
that it just isn't so simple.
The steam engine, for example, was
developed in the late 17th century
for a very practical purpose.
And this is characteristic
of engineering.
There's a purpose to what engineers
do, not just to understand,
but to produce something,
to accomplish an invention
or a new development in technology.
And in the late 17
century the purpose was
to pump water out of mines.
It was hard to mine coal if the
coal mine was full of water.
So the steam engine had that and
only that purpose originally.
Throughout the 18th
century it was developed
to be a much more versatile machine.
And, of course, when we
get to the 19th century,
the steam engine was put on
wheels and the wheels put
on tracks, and we had the railroad.
So this steam engine,
which is symbolic
of the whole industrial revolution,
really revolutionized the way we
not only experienced transportation,
but also by extension how we
experience society and culture.
It was only after really the
railroads had gotten started
that scientists seriously began
to look at the steam engine,
because now it was
something that existed.
It could be an object of
study in its own right.
And it was out of that
came a science
that we call thermodynamics
or the notion of heat.
The fact of the matter is that
the steam engine was developed
with virtually no science.
Another, I think, very persuasive
example is what the Wright Brothers
tried to achieve, mainly
powered flight.
The Wright Brothers recognized
when they were trying to design
and build their flying
machine that they had
to know somehow what shape
to make the propeller.
What would be the actual
curve of the propeller?
And, also, the wings were important,
but the propeller particularly
vexed them.
They even wrote to the Smithsonian
Institution here in the mall asking
for scientific results that would
help them develop an airplane.
Well, the answer they got back was
that there was a piosity
of really information.
And what did the Wright Brothers do?
Well, they didn't say, well we
can't go on and do engineering
because we haven't done
the scientific foundations.
They proceeded to do it themselves.
The Wright Brothers experimented
with different shapes and came
up with the shape of the
propeller that they use.
In engineering you don't have
to have the perfect answer.
You have to have an
answer that works.
And when they achieved
that, they were satisfied,
because they had a lot of
other things to do, too.
So the airplane, which again
revolutionized transportation
in the 20th century this time, was a
truly -- an engineering achievement.
The engineers welcomed all
the science they could get,
but there just wasn't
much in the beginning.
It was only after the airplane
was demonstrated to be effective
that true aerodynamics,
the science was developed.
Now, so what this suggests, this
little story, is that engineering
and science may be separate,
but there are overlaps.
And, furthermore, engineers
could actually do science.
And they often have to
in order to proceed,
in order to achieve their objective.
Because when you're trying
to develop something,
whether it be a steam
engine or a flying machine,
you evidently reach a
point in your pursuit
where you just don't know enough.
So you do have to get
some more knowledge.
But, generally speaking,
it's of such a practical kind
that it hasn't interested
science, and the engineers have
to do the science themselves.
Scientists also can
and do engineering.
Some people argue that a lot
of modern science especially
really wouldn't be getting very far
if it weren't for the engineering
that produces the machines
and the devices that
accelerate particles
to unheard of speeds and energies.
But let me tell a little
story about Albert Einstein.
Nobody will deny that he was
a scientist of the first rank.
It's generally known that
Albert Einstein worked
in the patent office
when he was young.
It's less generally known
that the reason he did
that is he couldn't get an
academic job as a scientist.
But he eventually, of course,
did publish significant papers.
He published them while he was
working in the patent office.
And those brought him
all sorts of recognition.
But publishing papers in science is
reporting on, you know, the facts,
the knowledge that has been
learned by the experiments
or the program that was pursued.
But what's less widely known
about Albert Einstein is
that he was also interested
in invention.
He was not only interested
in it through his work
at the patent office, but he was
interested in inventing himself.
And he was interested
not only in inventing,
but also patenting his inventions
and patenting his inventions
because he was interested in
profiting from his inventions.
And this is also a
characteristic of engineering.
Sometimes it's very difficult to
separate invention from engineering.
Back in the 1920s after Albert
Einstein had earned his Nobel Prize
or won his Nobel Prize, one
of the big practical problems
that the world faced was
with electric refrigerators.
They were new at the time,
but they had one big fault
or flaw -- well, actually two.
They had motors and they had
compressors, but they were noisy.
So refrigerators were noisy.
That was one thing, but that's
something you can live with.
There was a more deadly
problem with refrigerators.
And that was that all the noise,
all the vibration associated
with the motor and the
compressor shook up the system,
and it developed cracks,
and it developed leaks.
And that meant that the refrigerant
was being used could escape.
At the time the refrigerant that
was being used was poisonous.
So if a refrigerator sprung a
leak in the middle of the night
and a family was sleeping
and it wasn't detected,
then there would be a real tragedy.
And there were many newspaper
stories reporting on such tragedies.
Einstein read one of
these, so the story goes.
And he and his colleague
Leo Szilard, who had a pact,
a formal pact about inventing,
and that anything they
invented together,
they would have an
understanding of how the proceeds
of licensing the patent
would be divided.
They invented and patented in
several countries a refrigerator
that didn't have a motor,
didn't need a motor.
They used the principles of
thermodynamics to figure out how
to get this refrigerant, of course,
through the system and condense
and do whatever it had to do to
exchange heat without a motor.
And we would probably
have those kinds
of refrigerators today had
it not been for the fact
that at the same time the
refrigerator manufacturers
like say General Electric
figured out another alternative
to this deadly refrigerant problem.
And that was develop a new
refrigerant that isn't poisonous.
And that ended up being freon.
So the refrigerator companies were
introducing freon at the same time
that Einstein and Szilard were
trying to promote their machine.
And by simply changing the
refrigerant, that was a lot better
and more profitable for the
companies than Einstein's invention.
And so that was sort
of lost in history.
There is a serious scientist
doing serious science
who could also do engineering.
And that shows to me that there's
plenty of room for cooperation
between and among scientists
and engineers.
In fact, we hear the term
research and development a lot.
Research and development
roughly to a lot
of people means science
and engineering.
Too often it means that the research
is done and then it's handed
over to the development people
and there isn't the interaction.
So a lot of research and
development programs are not
as efficient as they might be.
These things are very
important in the present time,
because we hear a lot
about innovation.
The country needs a lot of
innovation, which is equated roughly
with invention, but it's
going beyond invention.
It's going not just getting the
patent, but also commercializing it,
something that Einstein and
Szilard were not able to achieve
because of the circumstances of the
times in which they were working.
But innovation brings new
industries, brings new ways
of life literally and also
enables things to be achieved
that might not otherwise.
But how do you achieve innovation?
Well, if you listen to
some of the politicians
in Washington here these
days, you achieve innovation
by throwing a lot of
money at science.
And just call up on Google, you
know, these stories reporting
on strategies to improve the
innovation in our country
so that we can improve the
economy and, therefore,
have a greater employment and
so forth in new industries.
It's not associated
with engineering.
It's associated with science.
I think this is a short-sighted
view.
And I think it really fails to
appreciate the lessons of history.
And I think unless there is a
more widespread understanding,
especially among those who write
the laws and vote on the laws
and are involved with public policy,
we're not going to see the kind
of innovation that we all really
want, including the politicians.
So coming around to where
I started, it shows I think
that if we really want to get
engineers and scientists together,
we have to stop separating
them in newspaper headlines
or in political speeches
or in political policies.
We have to be serious
that we recognize
that engineering is a very
important contributor to innovation
and to the way things are
done and will be done.
Let me just say one more
thing, one more anecdote,
and that has to do
with the steamship.
A lot of these stories have to do
with transportation and, you know,
consumer stuff, because
that's so important.
That's where innovation
is really going to happen.
In the early 19th century
steamboats were popular.
And they were mostly
on rivers, though.
And one of the reasons was it was
generally the case that these boats
that ran on steam that had steam
engines had to refuel regularly.
So they had to be close
to a source of fuel,
coal or wood or whatever they burn.
And, of course, if you're
near the coast or on a river,
that generally is not
too hard to do.
But the question was, what
about transatlantic shipping?
What about the sailing ships that
would come over from say England
over to Boston or New York?
Could you build a steamship that
could carry enough coal, let's say,
to make that voyage without
depending on sail at all?
That was a key question.
Now, that was very important,
because without considering that,
we would not have today what
we call scheduled shipping
or scheduled crossings.
Because before the steam engine was
applied to ships, relying totally
on the wind meant that you
relied totally on the weather.
And sometimes the wind blew
and sometimes it didn't.
That meant that if a ship left
say Liverpool and was heading
for Boston, you didn't know
when it was going to get there.
It could be two weeks or
it could be two months.
So you couldn't promise people
in Boston that there's going
to be a return trip to Liverpool.
You just didn't know when.
But with the steam engine, if you
were driving the ship regardless
of the weather, then you
could have scheduled shipping.
So it was truly a revolution.
Well, the scientists of the time --
I won't say "the," but some
scientists of the time said
that it was physically impossible,
it was against the laws of nature
that a ship large enough to carry
its own coal could be designed
and built.
They believed and they maintained
and they lectured on the fact
that the larger you make the ship,
the more coal you needed
to drive it.
And therefore, you know, you
just have endless growth of ship
without achieving your goal.
Well, engineers in the
1830s thought otherwise.
And they reasoned differently
from the laws of nature,
but the bottom line is that they
built steamships that did cross
under steam and carried
enough coal to do it.
And, in fact, later
they expanded that,
but that would be another story for
another time, because I did want
to allow some time for questions.
But just a few closing remarks,
and that is that this is what
the essential engineer is about.
And the subtitle is why
science alone will not solve our
global problems.
We need not only science,
but we need engineering.
We need a true partnership
between them.
And we need a recognition that there
is an equal status of engineers
and scientists in that they
contribute differently,
but they both contribute
to the objective end,
which is to effectively
innovate and change the world.
Well, thanks very much
for your attention.
And I would be very happy
to answer questions.
[ Clapping ]
>> Start over here on the left.
>> Yes. I'd like your response to
the conundrum and the controversy
about the collapse of three,
not two, but three towers
at the eastern end of Manhattan
eleven years ago this month
as if they were the products
of planned demolition.
Not only were these two towers --
two of these towers struck
by airplanes, in addition,
at least one other, another building
as tall as either of the twin towers
in this planet and
damaged as much as either
of the twin towers withstood
the shock and remained standing.
What are civil engineers
saying about this controversy?
>> You're talking about
I believe what is known
as World Trade Center Seven, a
building that was hit by some debris
and caught on fire and burned
essentially almost overnight,
as I recall, and eventually
did collapse.
The fact of the matter is that there
was so much attention being paid
to the World Trade Center towers
proper, World Trade Center Tower one
and two, which were much taller
than that World Trade Center seven,
by a factor of roughly two,
that that was not a big issue,
because people had been
evacuated from that.
And there was just
not the same concern.
But there are conspiracy
theories about the fall --
about the -- what did you call it?
Controlled demolition.
>> Yes
>> I think generally civil
engineers, structural engineers
in particular don't subscribe
to those conspiracy theories.
They believe, generally speaking,
that all three towers collapsed
largely due to two factors.
One was that by the planes striking
or the debris striking
these structures,
certain key structural
elements were damaged, columns.
If you take one of these poles
out from under this tent,
you don't expect the
tent to be as strong
as it is with all of its poles.
And that, secondly,
as the fires burned,
they naturally generated heat.
And the heat, if you heat
up these columns here,
they appear to be metal,
they're going to get soft.
And they're just not
going to have the strength
that they were intended to.
So as a result, eventually
this structure will collapse.
There are reasonable structural
engineering explanations
for those collapses.
Yes, sir?
>> As somebody who had his education
and career in engineering physics,
I'd be very interested in your
comments on the convergence
as we get into the nano region
of both theoretical physics,
theoretical -- let's
say theoretical science,
experimental science
and engineering.
They seem to be coming
together in this ring.
>> Well, that's right.
In order to produce especially
some of the electronic devices
and components that
are being projected,
you have to know a lot of physics.
And as I think it's a gosh example
of what I was saying is there
has to be close interaction.
I will say that it's hard to predict
what's going to happen or going
to be the limitations,
because almost
by definition we don't know what
they are, because we don't know
as much about the science
as we really should.
There's still open questions.
Yes, sir?
>> Yes. The previous two
speakers in this tent were dealing
with different issues, be it farm
produced poultry and products.
Edmund O. Wilson was here before.
I think the key to bridging science
and solutions is human factors
engineering and the expansion
of human factors engineering.
I haven't heard you speak on it.
Would you have an opinion on that?
>> Well, I didn't mention it today.
I have talked about human
factors engineering,
but human factors engineering
has various definitions.
To some people it means
simply making machines
that people can interact
with, that humans can interact
with without ambiguity
and with safety.
I think there are some
attempts to broaden the idea
of what human factors
engineering means.
And I think that's
a good development.
It's hard to be against
something like that.
And, well, I think it bodes well
for the objectives that we all have.
Yes, sir?
>> Given the failures of this decade
ending in 2010, what do you feel
about universities'
professors teaching engineers
for the global warming changes,
things that have come up?
Any challenges for the next decade
so that we maybe don't
have Katrina two,
gulf spill two, those
type of things?
Do you think we're prepared
enough going forward?
>> Well, you know,
Katrina sensitized people
to the weakness of levies.
And not only to the weakness of
levies, but also to the weakness
to the entire system that was
supposed to help New Orleans respond
to something of that nature.
The gulf spill, the recent gulf
spill has sensitized people
to deep water drilling and so forth.
So these failures will have an
immediate effect of making engineers
and people that commission
engineers a little more cautious,
a little more conservative.
So I would predict, if you're asking
me to predict, over the next decade
that we're not going to see
another Katrina in New Orleans.
We may see another Katrina
elsewhere, because so many
of the resources that it would
take to bring levies elsewhere
up to speed are really
going to New Orleans.
And there's just a
limit to, you know,
how many resources we can have.
The Netherlands, which has had
historically a levy problem,
if you will, is thinking
in terms of 200 years
and in some cases a millennium.
They are very long range thinking
and action on a national scale.
We haven't gotten to that point yet.
So I think we really have to look
elsewhere for some further lessons
about what we can do
to prevent disasters.
Yes?
>> Professor, you wrote a
book 11 or 12 years ago,
The Book on the Bookshelf.
>> Yes.
>> And in that you discuss many of
the things you brought up today,
invention, innovation,
the profit motive.
And in that context I wonder if you
would just address the evolution
in publishing today of E-Books
and P-Books [assumed spelling].
>> I wish I knew.
There is so much being reported
and written on that topic
that I will admit to being
bewildered about what's happening.
I think E-Books are a
natural development.
Whether they will actually
displace the physical book or not,
I think remains an open question.
And I think the publishers play more
of a role in this than they seem
to have admitted or
seem to be acting upon.
I think the publishers in a
certain way are silent partners
to the E-Book revolution.
It's a lot easier to produce and
more profitable to produce an E-Book
than it is a regular printed book.
I wish we would see more innovation,
innovated thinking on the part
of publishers with
regard to E-Books.
And I simply haven't seen it yet.
So I think that's going
to be the next wave
if the publishers are going
to really fight what they
claim they'd like to fight.
They're largely fighting it on
the basis of money and profit,
but not in terms of
technology in my opinion.
Yes, sir?
>> Yes. Professor, a lot of people
here don't realize that you're one
of the experts on failure analysis
and that you teach that at Duke.
And my question is,
the current modes
of failure analysis we see now, that
is, the software failures that is
like the 1990 national telephone
failure, I would say that is not
so much between science
and engineering,
but a failure between high level
engineering or systems engineering
and detailed engineering.
Essentially that failure was
because they wanted to save money,
they took the system engineering
specs and they brought it
into code instead of letting the
software engineer develop the
code himself.
My question is, I know your book
merge science and engineering.
What about in terms
of failure analysis,
what about systems engineering
and detailed engineering?
>> Well, I'm getting
the overtime sign.
So I'll be very brief.
And basically I'm working
on a book right now
that deals with those issues.
I'm interested in systems failures.
Well, thank you very much.
I'm sorry, but I've been told
we have to keep on schedule.
[clapping].
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.